Mark Norman everybody come
[Applause]
on thanks for coming out this is very
exciting I uh open for Seinfeld here
four years ago and now I'm headlining
and he's in the tunnels but um you know
good to be back this is pretty while i'
I walked past this theater 9 million
times to go bomb at a 60c comedy club
two blocks away where most of the
audience didn't speak English and uh I
don't know if you know about this art
form but it's pretty verbal and uh
that's a weird thing in New York all
these foreigners will go to a comedy
show and they don't speak English I'm
like that's like go to a museum if
you're blind you're like hey there's air
conditioning hey New York City how you
feel
tonight we got a hot show full of queep
and zingers you're in for a treat going
to bring up some of my favorite
Comics just got to say this is a dream
come true New York City thanks for
coming out I'm Kevin Hart appreciate you
I'm gay comedy thank you Qui it up I
love you than a good
[Applause]
[Music]
night